how would you
feel if this never ended
despite all the masks tests and
vaccinations
there is no guarantee that covet 19 will
ever disappear but stick with me on this
even if the virus doesn't go away
it might not be as bad as it seems
how could covet 19 never go away
what would life be like if it didn't
disappear
and how could the virus weaken
into another common cold
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if covet 19 never disappears
unfortunately there are a couple of ways
that covet 19
could be here to stay vaccines may not
be
completely effective animals could
infect us
again or the virus could
continue to mutate so
how might vaccines not do the trick
people don't always take well to
restrictive measures
like wearing masks and social distancing
vaccines are only effective if people
are willing to participate
if most people are vaccinated the virus
will have a hard time
finding someone who's susceptible
eventually
the spread will slow and die out
this is called herd immunity
but say a large number of people refuse
to get vaccinated
or socially distance the virus
would continue to spread in the future
vaccines could help stop the spread in
most areas but
there may be communities that don't get
or
don't take the vaccines as a result
localized outbreaks could occur
another way cobit 19 could continue to
spread
is the way it originated through animals
it isn't just bats and pangolins either
tigers at the bronx zoo and minks at a
dutch farm have had coveted 19.
without animal friendly practices the
virus could
live on and re-infect us even if it was
eradicated in humans
and there's a third way covet 19 could
stick around
mutation hey there's a lot to dive into
about covet 19 mutating
could it make the virus deadlier will it
render our original vaccines useless
check out our other video on what if the
coronavirus mutated
covet 19 might not go away but that's
not to say it
won't be manageable there are already
four other coronaviruses that regularly
circulate among humans
you've probably contracted one before
because they give you the common cold
these coronaviruses have been around for
decades
they cause mild illnesses in children
and
severe disease in the elderly but now
they've been around long enough for
people to slowly build up immunity
one of the reasons covet 19 is so deadly
is
because it's new our bodies have never
been exposed to this virus before
eventually years into the future our
immune systems could adapt to protect us
and all you'd experience is a few
sniffles
[Music]
and hey it's important to look past the
doom and gloom of what
life with covet has brought you know at
home
people have had more time to find new
passions and
spend time with their families companies
are rethinking their structure
including more options to work remotely
i'm voicing this from bora bora
with fewer people commuting to work the
environment has improved
global carbon emissions in 2020 were
eight percent lower
because of covet 19 restrictions
there isn't one solution that will make
covet 19 disappear
but slowly social distancing measures
might lighten up and people will be open
to shaking hands and
hugging in the future
this could just be another virus that
gives us the cold
but what would happen if you caught
covet 19
now how does it affect your body and
would you be treated well
that's a story for another what if